foreign
hey everybody it's Monday
which means it's time for us to talk
about a haunting I feel like this camera
moved either that or Spock moved maybe
Spock movies
oh Pokey must have done that
Pookie likes to love on Spock's leg I
thought it looks a little weird but I
thought it was like a little weird back
there she got a little overzealous I
guess with her affection on uh Mary Mary
Universe box leg there you humping uh
Spock's leg folk I don't know what she's
doing
I'm still trying to adapt to [ __ ]
drinking with a damn mustache I told you
and she should get a Mandy I got the
whole mustache the whole beard going on
but you can't really see it that much
because it's still kind of gray I got
some That Just For Men I'm gonna [ __ ]
dye that [ __ ] up you can see it's for
men it's gonna look like them
looks like um cross between the evil
Spock and um
Anton LaVey sure
Danny Rowling said Spock's boots were
made for humping evidently
Pookie has a shoe fetish
she really really likes messing with
people's shoes particularly Tom's shoes
but she likes to [ __ ] with my shoes too
but that's why I keep them closed up in
the closet she used to try to get inside
my whole booth yeah
Beijing did that too we found Beijing
like like sitting inside like a big like
goth boot one time but she was like was
yeah inside the boot
it's like super weird these kitties well
they're they're little female kitties
you know
they like the smell of leather and male
hormones stinky feet yeah stinky stinky
dudes and horses if anything that
smelled like horses or leather they like
that too yeah that's true they're weird
those kitties yeah they're weird
so Danny Rowling said the best thing
about this story though Ouija Hora that
we're going to be talking about today is
that the father of the six-year-old
ghost girl killed her killer who raped
and killed her yeah I saw that um they
didn't actually mention that on the show
but we'll get into that yeah I didn't
remember that from the show it wasn't on
the show
um I found that out in some supplemental
materials but I'm gonna say like I
didn't have a huge amount of time to do
a lot of background I did some
background research um about it but I
don't know what the original source of
that is you know what I mean yeah I kind
of feel like it's
it's almost kind of like the show like
the psychic going in there and saying
that stuff about like almost kind of
like fed into like everybody just kind
of like thinking that those people like
really exist so I don't really know if
they really maybe they do but um I don't
know I don't I don't know where the
actual uh source of it was I was kind of
excited because one of the first things
that I um thought of
or the or when I was like looking into
the thing and there was another article
that was fairly recent that had the last
name supposedly of the little girl that
was killed in there and I was like ooh
awesome so I looked it up and I was
excited because the first thing that
came up was like that find a grave you
know that find a grave site where it's
like every and I was like oh my God it's
a real person but then when I looked at
it
um it was just like somebody that had
obviously seen the episode and added her
to it and said you know Oh supposedly
she's buried at the witchy Pub or
whatever so there's no like grape for
her yeah same thing happens in religions
you start finding estuaries of people
that probably never lived and stuff like
that I'm not saying she didn't I'm just
saying interpolation I'm just saying
that um you know that the out that I was
excited because I thought I found like
outside verification like oh my God you
know they know who this little girl is
but then
because I even did like a newspaper
search like from because she supposedly
was murdered in 1908. they said and I
did like a newspaper search and I didn't
see anything like around that but like I
said it might just be because I didn't
dig down deep enough yeah the psychic is
a miniature little British um Sigourney
Weaver yeah because I would yeah we were
watching it I said oh my God she looks
like a lot like Sigourney Weaver yeah
and we were talking about how super
intense she was yeah mini Sigourney
Weaver yeah she's like an intense as
[ __ ] she really is she's probably still
around yeah I think that when that show
aired
um or at least it was like an article
that came out in 2004
which I guess was when the show aired
right and because this was season three
and they said at that point she was 32
which I thought she looked a little bit
older than that like she was just
carrying herself that I thought she's in
her 40s I didn't see it like you know
I'm not trying to be an [ __ ] or
anything I'm just saying that I thought
that she looked older than that but yeah
they said that she was 32. like she's
because she was intense maybe that's
what it was yeah she was like super
super serious which like I said you know
maybe this is like nothing to [ __ ] with
I'm just saying I know it's like me my
my butthole her delivery is good man she
sets your ass straight
she does there's really much yeah that
[ __ ] for real like exists yeah uh Danny
Rowling said she looks like Mia goth's
mom yeah she kind of looks like Mia goth
too but but being but Mia goth also kind
of looks like Sigourney Weaver a little
bit a little bit
so yeah I didn't even think about that
like just I don't know because she in
because in this one she had like hair
that was kind of like Sigourney Weaver's
hair in Ghostbusters I feel like that
kind of like big hermy like not like
that exactly but it was kind of like she
had a real real strong accent she kind
of sounds like she's uh Street wise
something out of a movie yeah like back
in the damn Oliver Twist days
she's gonna tell you give that boy some
food you know yeah I kind of got the
vibe it's like she maybe needs to like
play if they do like a um like a Stage
production of like a Jack the Ripper
thing she could be like the wise Kraken
like prostitute like you know what I
mean something like that yeah yeah
Oscar says uh Mia goth looks nothing
like Sigourney Weaver well I mean they
don't look that much alike I'm just
saying that this woman this woman kind
of looked like Sigourney Weaver but now
that he said she look kind of looks like
me a guy with like an old Mia goth like
I could see that too Mia got this she
was in uh X and she's in the new uh
Pearl Movie well she was 30 when she
made this 32 yeah 32 then I mean she's
about my age because this is
this is I think this was 2004. yeah so
it's almost almost 20 years yeah so
she's dinner in the 50s so yeah she's
about your age yeah I don't know if
she's still around I'm assuming she
still is but um because I think the most
recent article should probably watch it
yeah well there was kind of a there was
an article that was originally written
in 2004 and then it said it had been
updated in 2020 so I don't know what
what the update was but then there was a
more recent article that was from 2019
like summer 2019 and that was when they
said that there was another paranormal
group that was going to go in there and
like check it check it out but um I
looked on their website and I didn't see
anything they didn't have a search
function for one thing which I was just
kind of like okay well that's a little
inconvenient but like when I looked at
the um testimonials and stuff like that
like I didn't see anything so I don't
know if anything ever came out of that
or if they actually went or anything
like that because I couldn't find
anything I did find that paranormal
group they're still around but I don't
know if they ever went there or not but
I thought well this being like a pub
that's like a public place I kind of
thought that there would be more about
this but this kind of it keeps turning
up on like lists of like most haunted
pubs in the UK but there's not a lot of
history to it that's not already that
wasn't already delineated like on this
episode so I don't know if all of the
haunting stuff came from this episode
from this story and like I don't know if
it was considered haunted before this
episode came out I think it all comes
from her it might I'm pretty sure this
is her psychic revelation
that's kind of what I'm feeling like
because I know it's a possession
involved in it too yeah and and you know
stuff like that so we'll we'll see yeah
we'll talk about it but I think it's all
from that
yeah they had the guy that was got
temporarily possessed by the ghost
although he said he didn't remember it
like he had like a blackout essentially
is what happened dude that plays him in
the episode's [ __ ] awesome he says
some creepy [ __ ] that was the best part
like I thought that was the best part
like I that was that was scarier than
the ghost yeah we'll get into that but I
was like that was one of those moments
where I was like ooh that was so great
like that was so creepy like the way
because it wasn't overdone it was just
yeah see that's like way scary to me
remember when we were talking about we
didn't um do a full show on this episode
but we were talking about that episode
the possessed where I said that was that
there was that great [ __ ] moment
where the woman was supposedly possessed
and she was driving her kid in the car
and like she just kept staring at him
like over in the passenger seat like
while she was driving like ooh that's so
scary I love that
um it was a moment like that you know
what I mean where it wasn't over the top
it wasn't anything he just like said
some creepy [ __ ] like and it wasn't
overdone like the actress that was
playing that that woman she's she's in a
lot of episodes I just got a feeling
that she's [ __ ] wild she's probably
fun to hang out with because she looks
she looks she definitely having a good
time
with this material well yeah when she
was doing that driving absolutely
looking at that little boy
putting pedal to the metal going through
yeah
yeah
that was awesome but yeah that was like
a moment like in this one when the
Martin guy gets possessed and just says
follow the green paint yeah I'll get
into that yeah yeah but yeah that was
like super cute but that's why it was
scary because it wasn't super over the
top they didn't have like a lot of
Reverb on The Voice or anything like
that it was just like a regular voice
but a little bit weird sounding and that
to me is like way scarier than that
little British psychic chick jumping in
telling you what that [ __ ] means with
all her gravitas
right yeah she was kind of great yeah
she's she's pretty great you're like so
mad at all over twist it is yeah uh for
one second though good Lord can we
please talk about the terrible British
accents of the actors in this episode it
was oh my God it was making me it was
making me cry so hard well that's the
thing
um
yeah well the thing about it like I know
a haunting they generally have like just
like a stable of actors that they use
over and over um I didn't really
recognize any of them from this one like
from other episodes not saying that they
weren't in other episodes I'm sure they
were but uh so they come in and I'm like
oh this one's set in the UK so I'm sure
we're gonna hear some like really
cringe-worthy like Americans try to do
British accents and indeed uh there was
and I was just kind of like the whole
time of like oh my God please stop
talking it was just like really like
bothering me so I said I'm really
curious to see if they got any British
actors
um actual British actors or if they were
Americans so I went to the IMDb page and
I will say that most of the actors on
here didn't I mean they had like links
but they didn't really have like say
where they were from or anything but uh
for sure the guy that played Tim the
bartender one of the bartenders with the
British accent is from North Carolina
and the woman who and she actually had a
big part the woman that played uh the
bar manager in this like uh Camilla or
Camilla or whatever named Kamala I think
her name was
um that woman was from Queens New York
so actually hers was not great but it
was the best one out of all of them like
the other ones were like really really
bad really bad but uh yeah so I I just
thought that I would bring that up
because whenever they do one that said
in the UK I'm always just kind of like
I really wish they'd get actual British
actors or something instead of like
Americans Americans try to teach they
just throw that [ __ ] together in a
couple days each one of those that's
what I'm saying I guess and you know
it's not like they'd have the money to
like hire a dialogue coach or anything
like that they're just gonna go with it
but yeah we're just gonna go with it I
was just kind of like that I probably
shouldn't try Ed accents at all that's
kind of what I was thinking I would
rather they just talk in their normal
voices it's less distracting you know
what I'm saying uh but you know they
didn't and that's just how it happened
but like I said I just thought it was
funny I know that at least two of them
were Americans because I found them on
their IMDb page but so there's that
so
um you talk about something for a minute
because for some reason I really have to
go to the bathroom yeah I'm sitting here
real quick sitting here coughing
and then we'll get into talking about
the the episode yeah okay
I'm gonna use mine
okay
anyway
um
yeah been coughing
[ __ ] on that new [ __ ]
makes a car
every time I um
now I ain't gonna talk about it doesn't
matter see what else is in here
looks like a murder Hornet stepped out
for a second too
Oscar says shutter is killing it VHS 99
comes out later this month the VHS 85
just got announced I have no idea what
that is so the the must be the uh the
movie VHS I think
I think it was a long time ago wasn't it
cough drop won't help
sometimes you shoot that [ __ ] up and
it's kind of like you've just inhaled a
whole bunch of black pepper you just
start [ __ ] coughing and it feels like
uh somebody uh pour black pepper down
your spinal column just electric [ __ ]
Sparks and [ __ ] [ __ ] flying out
Mrs Evans says in hell no it doesn't
work
all right
okay
all right so what'd you guys talk about
while it's gone nothing nothing
um
Danny Rowling said another sick haunted
UK Pub would totally have to be the
ostrich Pub that inspired Sweeney Todd
the owner killed 60 people by a trapdoor
in the room we should probably do a show
about that actually
you know what I mean this one is what
you thought yeah okay that would be a
good show to do I should probably like I
don't know what happened to my pen
okay that's probably the one that used
to be over here
I'm going to write that down so I can
put it in my my list because I'm always
trying to like find new stuff to talk
about they I don't think they ever did a
um
a haunting show about that though
you know
all right are you ready
I don't have a big crowd better we
didn't really have a good crowd today I
guess everybody's uh doing something
else
yeah is it uh
maybe nobody likes this episode oh yeah
maybe I don't know I don't know I've
probably put it we can put it on the uh
we can put it on the member that
suggested it
no I had more than one person like
requesting this one
and actually this was on my list of the
ones that I wanted to do it's one of the
major episodes it is yeah and like I
said it's one that I remembered I guess
because the name was specific yeah it's
it's real memorable because they didn't
do like a lot of haunted pubs but it's
like yeah they did this one they did a
couple though yeah they did and like and
like Danny Rowling said this one was
kind of different because the [ __ ] was
like super violent uh apparently
but all right so yeah we talked about
like the terrible British accent so you
know no no shame like I know the actors
like didn't have a lot of time probably
to prepare for this and they're just
like can you do a British accent not
really well try it all right take you
know just keep on going so I just kind
of feel like that was what happened all
right so this pup I have the actual
address at the end of my notes if you
ever want to uh pop around and go there
I'm sure if you live in the area you
probably know where it is
so this Pub the Wheat Sheaf is in West
Bolden which is in Northeast England in
the tine River Valley
so apparently I don't know they said it
had been around for a couple hundred
years like most pubs uh have been
and I guess it had been closed at for
some time like uh because the guy that
was in there that bought it in 2004
whose name I think he said his name was
David guy I'm not sure if that was his
last name I didn't like I said that I
couldn't get the closed caption to come
on so I know his first name was David
for sure but I couldn't tell what his
last name was but it sounded like he was
saying guy
so he bought the pub in 2004 and he said
that prior to that it had been
um not abandoned but it had been closed
for I think he said seven months or a
year or more than that or something like
that but he said it had been like
boarded up and he's like it used to be
like one of the best pubs in town like
the best pub in town but it closed and
then like nobody really wanted to like
take it on me it was too much trouble or
something yeah yeah take it on what he
said yeah I guess that means deal with
it yeah he's a deal with it nobody
wanted to deal with it yeah yeah take on
the responsibility that's that's what he
meant yeah
um so uh so yeah so he bought it and
hired a whole new staff
and they said that after they're
reopening like business was really good
but pretty much they said as soon as
they opened as soon as people started
working there
um the staff in particular not so much
the customers I think there was kind of
one customer that they kind of went into
a little bit but the staff pretty much
immediately started reporting like
Paranormal phenomena like as soon as
they started working there
so the one woman who's the bar manager
now I think like um Anthony called the
narrator he pronounced her name as
Kamala he said camela now I looked it up
and her name is actually spelled
k-a-m-y-l-a-h which to me looks like
kamyla but I could totally be wrong
about that so I don't really know I'm
gonna say Camilla because that's what it
looks like to me
um but he said camela and I was like
that doesn't that doesn't sound like how
you pronounce that but whatever
so she was the bar manager and she said
that even from the beginning they uh she
said we always felt like we were being
watched like all the time we were in
there
and she said you know I've worked other
places I've never felt scared before
like that before I started working there
she said because it's just a really
creepy like feeling of being watched all
the time so the first kind of major
thing that happened other than that was
that um she went into the kitchen now it
looked like I don't know if this is what
the real Pub looks like but it looked
like on the show that the kitchen was
like upstairs and they said they
generally kept it locked like when the
pub wasn't open or like after hours or
whatever
and she said that she went up there one
night and she said the fridge doors they
had the big industrial refrigerator and
she's like the fridge doors were open
even though the kitchen had been locked
and nobody had been in there and she had
made like a pan of she says me jelly uh
she said jelly but it says Jello if
you're from the United States it's a
thing of jello uh for you know jello
shots she made like a big thing for
jello shots and she pulls the pan out
and there was like a little kid's
handprint like in the in the top of the
jello and she's like yeah so nobody had
been in the kitchen it had been locked
um and obviously there are no kids in
the pub
so she's like that was super super weird
she said that pretty much every day
there was something different going on
like you never knew it was gonna happen
just like there would always be
something moved or like some other weird
[ __ ] that was going on she's like the
fridge doors would be open it's like or
something like that it was always
something so just all the time there was
something going on that's what she said
like every day
so Tim one of the bartenders uh has also
heard customers uh describing having
paranormal experiences in the pub so
they then showed and I don't know who
this woman was I'm just assuming that
they're like using this as like an
example of hey customers like saw weird
[ __ ] too so there's a woman in the
bathroom like fixing her lipstick or
whatever and she sees a little girl
behind her like in the mirror and she
thinks it's a real kid obviously so she
turns around and she's like hey little
girl or whatever but then when she turns
around like the little girl isn't there
so she's like huh that's pretty weird
and like she looks around and the Stalls
and everything and doesn't see her so
then she goes out into the hall and sees
the little girl again but the girl looks
kind of ghosty you know what I mean
she's not like transparent or nothing
but she kind of looks like a little
ghosty but like I said they didn't
really have
any of the customers other than Martin
but we'll talk about him later but they
didn't really have like this woman in
particular like the real one or anything
so I don't know but it did seem like
from what they said I kind of feel like
maybe some customers did say that they'd
seen a little girl like in the bathroom
like maybe more than one person said
they saw that I mean that was that was
the impression that I got I'm not really
sure
so David the guy that owns the place
he's like yeah we heard weird [ __ ] all
the time like included they said they
would hear footsteps all the time
knocking or banging sounds coming from
upstairs when obviously no one was up
there like after closing and they'd
already been up there cleared it out
um so just for shits and giggles and
because
I don't know like I guess this was kind
of like
um he seemed a little more Earnest like
the real guy like the actor seemed a lot
more like hey let's let's see what the
ghost has to say blah blah blah I made
this Ouija board like he pulls up this
tape the tablecloth and it looks like he
made you know he just like wrote letters
on pieces of paper and they like put it
under a piece of glass or something like
that and then they just like use the
glass like to do the Ouija board with so
they're gonna play it one night we're
like we're gonna figure out like who
this is is walking around up there
because obviously it's a ghost right
so uh they ask it like who is it that's
like walking around up there
and the thing uh whatever it is like
apparently spells out at first it says
get out uh which you know rude and then
um they kind of hear a bunch of creaking
and [ __ ] and they're just like what the
[ __ ] man like what is that and then like
the message continues uh get out or I'll
kill you which that's even Ruder you
know
so uh then they all take their hands off
the glass like what the [ __ ] like that's
that's not right and then the glass like
starts moving by itself and then it
spells out help me
now supposedly then or at least this is
what they showed on the show they hear
something that sounds like a little girl
sighing or do or something making some
kind of like little girls